a stunning development at the ellen
degeneres show
an official investigation is underway
after nearly a dozen complaints about a
hostile work environment
if you're on daytime television every
single day i think it's really important
to feel like
there's someone that that makes you feel
like a pal like a friend
i love making people happy i've always
wanted to be the voice for people who
felt like they didn't have a voice
because i know what that feels like
an investigation of this size could take
anywhere from three to six months
this will consist of uh what i imagine
will be thousands of hours of interviews
the internal investigation into ellen's
show was launched just days after
buzzfeed published this
article describing what it called a
toxic work culture
it claimed a former worker walked off
the job because she was fed up with
comments about her race
and others according to buzzfeed said
they were instructed by managers quote
to not speak to degeneres if they saw
her around the office
nbc news citing a source says ellen
herself is not part of the investigation
i don't know by contemporary standards
that you could call an investigation
of the ellen show thorough if you didn't
interview
its host and executive producer and
creator
all of this is complicated by another
factor ellen's brand and image
kindness we bought you a house
i think that i was a nice person to
begin with and i hope i've gotten nicer
she sort of took this mantle from oprah
of giving and i think that when there's
behavior that runs
contradictory to that it really really
upsets people
a few years ago i started ending my show
by saying be kind to one another here's
the downside
i can never do anything unkind ever now
i can't do the things you do because i'm
the be kind girl
ellen has not commented on any of the
claims but the show's executive
producers responded to the buzzfeed
article saying
the day-to-day responsibility of the
ellen show is completely on
us adding we have strived to create an
open safe and inclusive work environment
one of the things i learned from the
america's gut challenge investigation is
mvc installed
sort of fail-safe system to report any
grievances
which i think sources would inarguably
say had not been there before
so so the ellen show could actually do
something similar
you